hi my name is Chris Martin and I feel
really great about being Conan O'Brien's
friend that's sweet I feel great about
being here with you I'm uh I don't know
what we just did we tried to high five I
think I put my hand out in the incorrect
way we reached across the aisle we did
immediately fell in love with you once
our hands touched yeah I fell in love
with you years ago so very sweet well
you know it's nice you and the The Gents
from Coldplay did the show a number of
times and then you came on and we
chatted once but I've always wanted to
do this every time I've run into you you
seemed like a fascinating smart witty
guy but in that other format I can't
just sit and talk to you and sort of a
chat show format
it's six seven no it is supposed to be
the idea but in America anyway once you
have the band and all the comedy
sketches and everything else you never
really get the time to get to know
somebody I also felt that in the chat
show um hierarchy singers are right at
the bottom I don't know if that's true
it's like we've got this guy juggling
koalas he's on before you then the guy
that was was once on a rerun of a pilot
he's on before you and then at 2 A.M
we're going to talk to you for one
minute yeah and then we're gonna cut to
uh yeah okay cool Chris in defense the
koala guy was amazing he was amazing
those were live koalas most of them were
not injured what was I was looking at
the other day I just came across tape of
The Beatles on Ed Sullivan and they have
like people you know doing tricks with
monkeys and you know crazy acrobats and
then it's like time for The Beatles and
you're thinking this is what is it about
this why would you even have any kind of
show other than just you've got the
Beatles you just have them on I'm happy
we're talking about this because we just
did um SNL last week which we love doing
so much and Pedro Pascal was hosting
yeah I saw it and he was amazing yeah it
just sort of reminded me that
it's great to have someone famous come
on TV but it's really great to have
someone who really knows what they're
doing and can act and yes I think it's
the same for talk shows you know there's
great guests and there's probably one so
you have to scrape the barrel a bit oh
I'm happy to name names but also if you
think about like all the competitive
music shows the The Voice you know you
have to remember everything is a TV show
or the Grammys is that's what it is
first and foremost and so even if you're
the most interesting composer in the
world it might not be great TV right
that's the way I've always looked at it
we know I'll tell you that this is
something that I think it's exceptional
for actors in the UK many times which is
over the 30 years that I was doing that
TV stuff I noticed that uh American
actors
I mean I'm talking about great actors
terrific actors top of the top they
mutter their they give one syllable
answers they don't want to ever smile
because that's not cool they've all been
influenced going back to James Dean but
then I'd have these people on like
Richard Harris I'd have these uh British
actors on who of the best acting chops
in the world and they're Raconteurs yeah
they love to be funny and they tell
stories and I mean I was always Blown
Away by that there's something about in
the UK where no no you need to be able
to tell a story you need to be able to
land a joke it's it's in the blood I
think I mean that comes from the
different types of training or the you
know the more theatrical background in
London or what do you think it's from I
think it's the tall poppy syndrome it's
the same thing with the Irish the
English the Scottish they're very
self-aware you can't if you get too big
someone else will chop you down if you
if you get a big head if you're you go
get too big someone else will let you
know it whereas American actors can take
themselves really seriously and there's
no one around to say
shut your face you're acting like an
idiot and I think that's to me that's
where the difference is yeah
yeah okay all right well that's all the
time we have
um I'm just here to tell you things that
I've I've got a new thing in my life of
if someone says something that I don't
necessarily agree with I just say okay
great
[Laughter]
rather than I I don't really know okay I
don't I'm trying to remove any conflict
in terms of we've tried for years to
sort of see if the the sort of way of
changing people's minds is telling them
they're wrong and I don't think it is I
definitely feel that more strongly than
ever so I'm trying to just listen I mean
you're a light a lighter example I'm
talking about if someone's talking about
fascism or this or that well I was gonna
get to fascist okay and I think there
are a lot of advantages okay
[Laughter]